[Musique]
regardez ce que je vous présente
aujourd'hui
l'excellent cow boys 3 c'est le nouveau
vélo de l'entreprise belge du même nom
cowboys qui vous présente sa toute
nouvelle monture alors ça fait quelques
jours que je ride et la ville avec de
tous les côtés c'est un vélo qui est
très surprenant et sur plusieurs points
il ya notamment une courroie en fibre de
carbone tu vous donner tous ses secrets
vous le présenter sur tous les points
et vous allez voir franchement il
déchire c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui
est réalisé en partenariat avec clic
clic c'est une assurance d'un nouveau
genre qui va venir vous permettre de
prendre soin de votre vélo de prendre
soin de vous et surtout de venir à
l'assuré dans meilleures conditions
parce que oui un produit comme le cow
boys 3 coûte quand même plus de deux
mille euros c'est un vélo qui a une
certaine valeur et il faut venir
l'assuré quand on parle d'assurance de
vélo on parle pas uniquement de protéger
le bien on parle également de protéger
les personnes parce qu'ici vous avez
différents types de couverture grâce à
cliquer la base de la base de la base ce
sont les dommages accidentels
ça veut dire qu'en cas d'accident les
dommages causés aux vélos de manière
involontaire et qui empêche son bon
fonctionnement
vont être pris en charge par l'assurance
mais vous avez également ensuite des
options à tiroirs notamment contre le
vol
si quelqu'un vous voler votre vélo alors
vous êtes dessus ce qu'on va plessis du
vol avec violence ou de l'intimidation
et bien vous êtes couvert mais vous êtes
également couverts si quelqu'un a cassé
votre anti vol est parti avec votre vélo
vous avez une autre option c'est la
responsabilité civile qui va venir vous
couvrir pour les dommages causés à
autrui dans le cas d'un accident dans
lequel vous serez responsable et tout ça
jusqu'à une valeur maximale de 300 mille
euros il ya également une protection
juridique si vous avez besoin d'un
avocat
klink va vous en a signé un sans limite
de frais ou alors vous pouvez choisir
vous même votre avocat à hauteur de 2000
euros d'honoraires
c'est vraiment important de réfléchir à
sare vous avez un engin qui vous emmène
sur la route et d'autres conducteurs il
ya des piétons il faut prendre soin de
vous des autres et également de votre
vélo qui c'est une assurance qui est
100% online vous
inscrivez depuis leur site cliquer point
fr et vous gérer tout le reste
depuis l'application souscription mais
également déclarations et gestion des
sinistres clics vous couvre dans le
monde entier
vous pouvez donc prendre votre vélo et
voyager avec votre assurance et sans
carences et en cas d'accident il sera
réparé très rapidement avec une garantie
de trois mois sur les réparations bonne
nouvelle avec clic on vous offre parra
vol qui va devenir obligatoire à partir
de la fin 2021 là où normalement vous
allez pouvoir assurer votre qu'au bac 3
pour 9 euros 93 par mois grâce aux liens
que je vous ai mis en bas dans la
description et au code vous allez le
payer 7 euros 44 donc ça c'est un vrai
bon plan clics vous permet d'assurer
bien plus que votre vélo vous va sur
également votre smartphone ou votre
tablette vos écouteurs audio votre
console de jeux pensez donc à découvrir
clic en passant par les liens que vous
aimez en bas dans la description pour
assurer tous les objets qui vous
tiennent à coeur
première chose sur son vélo c'est le
confort la position est vraiment bonne
moi je me sens vraiment hyper en
sécurité la tenue de route est vraiment
super super super agréable et lorsque je
me penche dans les virages que je vais à
fond avec mon vélo jusqu'à 25 km parce
que ça c'est la loi française qui nous
oblige au niveau de l'assistance
électrique et bien je peux vous assurer
que me sens vachement sécurité pour ni
ride et en toute circonstance pour ça
c'est super cool le tout est vraiment
génial sens vélo si vous avez une
courroie en fibre de carbone vous n'avez
pas une chaîne n'est pas des dérailleurs
n'ai pas besoin de changer de vitesse ce
n'est surtout pas d'huile guérir tout
accroché à votre pantalon donc ça c'est
extrêmement clean c'est très pratique
vous mettez sur le vélo vous pédalez et
lui fait le boulot il vous assistent
mais l'expérience est vraiment bien
vous n'avez plus qu'à prendre votre vélo
rail d evo est parti pour bâle pour du
monde mais presque et vous n'avez pas
besoin d'entretien jusqu'à 30000 km et
autre point qui est vraiment bien
vous avez des pneus anticrevaison et
pour faire démonter okot les doigts
d'emmener votre batterie se situent
aussi à l'arrière vous avez une petite
clé pour venir la retirer
vous prenez vous tournez vous enlever la
batterie elle fait quand même ici 2 kg 5
vouloir charger en trois heures et demi
et elle vous emmène jusqu'à 70 km est ce
un vélo qui fait 16,9 kg
[Musique]
vous avez un phares à led à l'avant mais
également l'arrière ça c'est une option
garde-boue arrière guerre de boue avant
puis 89 euros de plus mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut quand même y avoir un côté
très pratique on a un frein à disque à
l'avant mais également à l'arrière et ce
qui est très pratique c'est que vous
avez votre voyance batterie qui est
situé juste ici comme ça vous savez
toujours vous en êtes pour ne pas finir
sans assistance électrique il est
disponible en trois couleurs le noir
comme ça c'est vraiment la plus jolie
couleur il ya également un gris et un
blanc ce qui est aussi intéressant si
vous pouvez venir régler la hauteur de
votre selle néanmoins ici le guidon on
reste comme ça on peut pas le monte donc
plus vous allez monter la scène et plus
vous allez vous pencher mais en terme
d'expérience comme il est là
personnellement pour moi c'est parfait
[Rires]
et c'est un vélo qui est dispo tarifs de
2280 disons avec votre vélo cowboys vous
avez une petite boîte avec pas mal
d'accessoires vous avez notamment une
petite sonnette
bon moi je n'ai pas rêvé mais vous
pouvez la mettre si vous le souhaitez
vous avez retrouvé également un petit
guide pour venir aider tout savoir sans
votre vélo ça c'est assez rigolo
ici vous avez de quoi venir l'installer
à vous avez deux créent les clés comme
ça qui vous servira à venir retirer
votre batterie pour tenir la charge et
éviter qu'on vole pique donc ça c'est
plutôt sympa en dessous vous avez
effectivement vos quitte avec vos
pédales que vous installez c'est très
simple et quelques petits accessoires
notamment des petits réfléchissent
heures vous avez un petit fois en plus à
venir installer ça tape force mais
surtout ici votre vélo et bien ce piloté
depuis votre application qu'au bruit sur
votre écran d'accueil vous allez pouvoir
venir l'allumer ou l'éteindre vous avez
qu'à faire un appui long ici tac votre
vélo s'allument pour trouver les
informations essentielles
le nombre de kilomètres qui vous reste
peu de batterie si vous le posez sur le
vélo vous verrez votre vitesse en temps
réel pouvait venir
allumer ou éteindre les phares coupé ou
réactivée l'assistance électrique vous
retrouvez la distance que vous avez
effectué le nombre de kilos de co2 qui
ont été sauvées vous pouvez les
retrouver en cliquant ici sur find my
bike qui va vous dire une dernière fois
où est-ce qu'il l'a vu et à quelle heure
vous pouvez venir le bloquer
automatiquement si vous souhaitez si
vous ne l'utilisez plus d'une minute
cinq minutes 10 minutes 30 minutes il va
venir s'éteindre automatiquement vous
avez une détection des accidents ça
c'est assez cool j'ai pas encore activé
vous venez là
suivez ici est en dessous vous avez
votre numéro d'urgence qui va venir
contacter en cas d'accident vous avez
également un historique de voyage
que ce soit par jour par semaine par
mois également pas vous l'aurez compris
c'est un vélo que j'aime beaucoup que je
trouve vraiment cool pour se balader en
vie pour ride et tous les côtés je peux
que vous recommander c'est le cow boy
iii c'est le terreau est vrai bien lien
au bas des skippers
[Musique]